reporter wird ihnen präsentiert von
webforum die business konferenz für
digitale revolution atomkrieg
arbeitslager und angst das ist nordkorea
einige module schaffen es ja auch nicht
aus dem aus dem image von dem land hat
aussprache also tun alle ist es in der 2
das bild
das ist propaganda was ist wahr
auch der diplomat thomas kessler weiß es
nicht
auch nach vier jahren in pjöngjang
dass das land eine so ist wie sie sich
wahrscheinlich warum wir
er lebt in einer der schlimmsten
diktaturen der welt am rande eines
atomkriegs angst hatte aber nie danach
richtet die terroristen ausschlägt und
vernimmt
von europa über afrika bis nach asien
führte ihn sein leben stets in
begleitung seiner familie familie
gründet oder schoko warum gibt's sonst
alles zusammen
und jeden morgen um sagte betroffen ich
fahre nicht statt hier oder unter
missachtung sieben werden noch nicht vor
dass das zurück
jetzt geht er in pension die nächste
aufgabe wartet schon
wir werden großeltern mittelzusagen so
wichtig sind es muss als großvater darum
mit dem baby und kinder gestoßen
ein kind damals hosen dies interessant
dann gehst du am stock
[Musik]
unsere reise beginnt am nagelneuen
flughafen mit mulmigem gefühl betreten
wir das letzte land hinter einem
eisernen vorhang hier arbeitet thomas
kessler für die entwicklungshilfe der
schweiz
er leitet das büro der deetzer
er ist unser schlüssel zu einem land in
dem journalisten nur ganz selten etwas
hinter die kulissen schauen dürfen
dank seiner langjährigen kontakte sollen
wir mehr sehen als die übliche fassade
nordkoreas willkommen im reich der kind
willkommen im land der gegensätze
das sind dass er ganz wenige so leichter
wo das dass ich nun möglich wie im regen
doch vielleicht ist das großes maß an
vertrauen
[Musik]
angestellte minister weiß damit die
woche kann man machen wird nachher nicht
doch auch mein kollege von der neuen
zürcher zeitung und ich sollen erst
einmal die wichtigsten kommunistischen
monumente sehen
[Musik]
begleitet werden wir von zwei lokalen
mitarbeitern der dcc schauen sonst
thomas fiedler auf die finger
ich habe jedoch nicht vorstellen dass
das das müsst ihr so lange das ist schon
speziell und die cs eigentlich wollte
sein zu hause versteckt sich hier
abgeschirmt hinter den mauern des
diplomatischen bezirks hier wohnt und
arbeitet thomas wissler seit vier jahren
von hier aus koordiniert er die
humanitären einsätze im auftrag der
schweiz
wer in nordkorea arbeitet muss sich dem
regime ständig unterordnen
ich habe mir noch gut die lupe per se
und sich der tüte mehrere plattformen
dass hier bis vor island und dem sie
nicht vertragen oder beitragen als
information mehrheit
durch seine arbeit hat thomas kessler
einen tieferen einblick in nordkorea als
andere
[Musik]
4000 haushalte haben in diesem dorf
neuerdings fließendes trinkwasser
dank schweizer hilfe 8 millionen franken
hilfsgelder fließen jedes jahr aus der
schweiz nach nordkorea
die schweiz ist damit eines der größten
geberländer in nordkorea
das öffnet auch uns schweizer
journalisten tore die sonst verschlossen
bleiben aber als land ist das alter in
seinem besitz zu bedienen
durch diese eigene rente typisches who
so ist im ganzen land die micky ist ein
halber meter tiefe durch für stellt man
die kochtöpfe erschwindeln holzofen oder
die usa und dann gehört aber da der
rauchabzug hat durch die pforte du so in
eine schlange und am schluss des
höchster - der abzug funktioniert und
dann ist sie immer cookie und der boom
hält die vom hof fahren und die andere
daneben eigentlich was menschen exotisch
wie hat dass es im internet einkaufen
ist - 20 25 grad
außerdem sind verhärtet thomas wissler
mag seine arbeit im büro wird es dem
einstigen maurer schnell zu eng im feld
blühte auf perfekt gemacht auch diese
hänge sind ein hilfsprojekt der deetzer
hier geht es um wissensvermittlung die
bauern lernen wie man hänge sichert und
dabei gleichzeitig erträge erzielt wenn
thomas wissler sieht wie die arbeit
seines teams früchte trägt weiß er warum
es ihn immer wieder in die entlegensten
winkel unserer erde gezogen hat sofort
dass ich die fehler anderer
landwirtschaft ein auf ich hatte diesmal
zu jever rapids lindenbaum und oder
harry potter und diskutiert was man
alles nochmal machen und da es einzig
ist immer genial es in yahoos bildet
also sind alle gute schulbildung
[Musik]
nach zwei tagen verlassen wir das
ländliche nordkorea wieder über die
wichtigste verkehrsachse des landes
holpern wir in richtung piani an
[Musik]
wie ein großer fremdkörper taucht die
hauptstadt plötzlich aus den reisfeldern
auf der kontrast zur armut auf dem land
könnte kaum größer sein
noch deutlicher wird dies im supermarkt
wo thomas fessler noch kurz einkauft
fürs abendessen dass seine frau hilda
für uns vorbereitet
hier kaufen nicht nur ausländer ein
sondern auch reiche nordkoreaner 12 das
tun sie das haus und die chance für das
zunehmend häufig geht wo importiertes
vorfeld hatte man nicht viel speck so
oder so und dann kriegen die eier das
problem
[Musik]
wer hier lebt muss flexibel bleiben das
weiß auch seine frau hinter aufgewachsen
ist sie in kamerun als erwachsene hat
sie ihr zuhause oft gewechselt
es komme immer gerne aus den ferien
zurück hier sind alle meine sache ich
fühle mich da zu hause wo ich gerade
während jetzt ist mein zuhause
doch manchmal wird es auch etwas einsam
im abgeschotteten haus und
diplomatischen bezirk wenn freunde
einladen müssen sie das anmelden viel
freiheit bleibt da nicht der kontakt zur
lokalen bevölkerung ist beschränkt durch
immer dumme vermutlich ins akquise drei
kontakte oder hand einfach angst
umso wichtiger ist für fischers der
kontakt zu ihren drei erwachsenen
kindern die längst verstreut in der
ganzen welt leben
das internet macht's möglich selbst im
abgeschotteten nordkorea als diplomaten
genießen sie freien zugang zum netz
die webcam gibt uns das gefühl dass wir
mit der familie zusammen sehen wir sehen
uns mit diplomatischen privilegien kann
man auch in nordkorea gut leben
doch schon am nächsten morgen tauchen
wir wieder ein in die andere realität
von nordkorea unsere begleiter haben uns
einen touristen programm
zusammengestellt im auftrag des
außenministeriums
vorbei ist es mit unseren kleinen
freiheiten auch wir sollen zu hause das
zeigen was ein durchschnittsbesucher von
nordkorea sähen sollen zb die u-bahn aus
sowjetzeiten ein punkt bei der fast
schon wie ein museum wirkt
[Musik]
und weiter geht sind touristen programm
als nächstes sollen wir glückliche
nordkoreanische schüler sehen weit weg
scheint hier die armut die wir gestern
noch auf dem land gesehen haben weit weg
scheint hier die wirkliche realität des
landes
doch thomas fiedler ist das längst
gewohnt solchen show veranstaltungen bei
zu boden
[Musik]
also wir werden die botschaft also
positiv dramatische und so weiter mehr
als nötig für vorteile sachen können
anzeigen kinderheim
prompt eine fabrik in sonderschulen
sie sind einfach so ist für so
deswegen bin ich hier um ganz genau
aufzeigen
das ist sozusagen sich wie schreiben
sicherlich schon mal das zeigen ihre
aufstoßen
[Musik]
in solchen momenten gerät thomas fessler
immer häufiger ins grübeln wieso glaubt
man dass mich so zu haupt
und opa
ärgerlich für mehr was das eigentlich
ist je länger er hier ist desto mehr
fragen hat er es sei vielleicht der
richtige zeitpunkt bald zu gehen
das gibt sondern erst iv sei aber man
findet erstaunlich nah kommt roux setzt
motors c und zogen das sind der euregio
und dann endlich die lang die zweite
phase wo wo immer ein fragezeichen ruft
da auch immer mehr immer weniger oder
gar keine satzung und so die letzte
phase nicht befehlen beobachten da geht
man allen sinnen erfahren ist ich hoffe
dass ich mal richtung nach einer
reichlichen der villigster hygienisch
und akustisch und so dass das sehe ich
befehle
doch es reicht noch nicht für heute
wir müssen auch den kinder palast
bestaunen hier werden elite kinder auf
höchstleistung getrimmt
[Musik]
schon das zuschauen schmerzt was ist das
für ein land das fünfjährige zu
spitzenmusikern heranzüchtet selber
nuklearraketen baut aber seine
bevölkerung mit knurrenden mägen zu bett
schickt es ist ein groteskes theater zu
gerne würde thomas fiedler tiefer hinter
den vorhang schauen
[Applaus]
fröhlichkeit der hindern
ich hoffe und ich danke dass ich
letztendlich ist es schwierig heiter
dass es der letzte schritt vor der vom
vertrauen und das aber nie bis ganz
schwierige der mann das ist hier die
barriere zwischen teuer sondern nach
acht tagen verlassen wir nordkorea
auch wir haben mehr fragen als antworten
drei monate später treffen wir thomas
fessler wieder diesmal in oerlikon am
ort wo er geboren wurde
er ist in die schweiz gereist um seinen
ersten enkel zu bestaunen
die lage in nordkorea hat sich
zugespitzt er bleibt gelassen
bald wird er pensioniert was danach
kommt weiß er nicht da ist dann das dass
das weiß ich wirklich nötig ich glaube
ich haben unterdessen über all die hits
wie hey ich jetzt endlich viele
parteikollegen und bekanntenkreis ich
wohl mal wieder als plug-in wo sich
mögliche irgendwo so stifter alt
viel hat sich verändert seit daher vor
50 jahren seine lehre machte thomas
wissler will uns deshalb an einen ort
führen wo alles beim alten geblieben ist
er fährt mit uns zu einem alten freund
in dessen italienisches restaurant
[Musik]
nichts zu machen in der schweiz hält man
sich eben an öffnungszeiten
doch der oerlikon aus nordkorea weiß
noch ein anderes lokal aus seiner
jugendzeit
wenn thomas fiedler etwas gelernt hat in
seiner zeit im ausland ist es
flexibilität stadt zum italiener fahren
wir in sein elternhaus nach dem tod
seiner mutter hat er es geerbt umgebaut
und die oberen stockwerke vermietet
geboren und aufgewachsen und da ein
stück los
da bin ich 26 bei aller nostalgie
hierher zurück will er trotzdem noch
nicht
dennoch schaffen es bis machen wo
arminia volk nach bruch verehrte also
ich könnte mir vorstellen für irgendeine
nichtregierungsorganisation oder sowohl
qualitativ muss ja dann muss unter
kritik mitbringen und das machen was
dank ich fürchte zum primat also nur
einfach geht es da
und so bleibt die schweiz wohl für
fischers auch nach der pensionierung vor
allem eine feriendestinationen wie bis
anhin werden sie von zeit zu zeit in
diesem kleinen studio im keller des
elternhauses wohnen und in erinnerungen
schwelgen
[Musik]
das ist die cross in afghanistan dass
ich doch jetzt tief der richtige
biertische darf als auch wieder fahren
gar nicht irgendwie alles schon auf
viele einfache gesehen
zu den erinnerungsfotos aus der
jugendzeit kommen ab jetzt die enkel
fotos hinzu vor einer woche wurde der
jüngste spross der siebte geboren
zusammen mit oma und opa thomas besuchen
wir die frischgebackenen eltern und so
schließt sich ein kreis
[Musik]
spannend werden die vier jahren haben
die oberhand
das haben wir drehen sind wie ich damals
so damit dahin
jetzt kommt es ist einfach ein großes
geschenk
ich bin sehr gerührt
das ist nicht selbstverständlich
ich bin glücklich
[Musik]
reporter wurde ihnen präsentiert von
world webforum die business konferenz
für digitale revolution